♪♪
Gaal:
When I was a child, at the edge
of the galaxy...
♪♪
Gaal:
I heard stories about a man who
could forecast the future.
♪♪
Gaal:
But the story remained dark to
me until many years later.
♪♪
Gaal:
Until it became my story.
♪♪
Gaal:
Until it became the only story.
♪♪
Hari:
You're familiar with my work,
psychohistory?
Every mathematician has read
your theory.
-It's not a theory.
Hari:
It's the future of mankind
expressed in numbers.
Hari:
And the empire won't like the
future I predict.
♪♪
History is littered with
charlatans and false messiahs.
♪♪
We should kill them.
Brother Day:
We can murder the man, but what
about the movement, brother?
♪♪
Martyrs tend to have a long
half-life.
♪♪
Gaal:
His math was right.
The empire is dying.
♪♪
Wars will be endless.
(Men yelling)
Hari:
A thousand worlds reduced to
cinders.
♪♪
Hari:
Change is frightening.
♪♪
Hari:
Especially to those in power.
♪♪
Hari:
But we can soften the fall.
♪♪
So what's the plan?
Hari:
Many years from now,
if humanity is to climb from the
ashes,
♪♪
Hari:
the coming generations will need
the knowledge to build upon,
a foundation.
♪♪
Gaal:
We must preserve only the most
essential pieces of
civilization.
♪♪
Gaal:
Deciding what is remembered,
♪♪
Gaal:
what is forgotten.
♪♪
Man:
We are now staring down the
barrel...
♪♪
Man:
...of a crisis.
♪♪
This is the plan.
Gaal:
We're not turning around now.
♪♪